hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast open targets platform
mining gene and disease evidence for
improved drug target selection presented
by dr. Denis Z Carvalho Silva scientific
outreach officer open targets symbol EBI
I'm julissa Morales of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth the leading scientific social
networking websites and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation for
questions not answer today we will
follow up with participants via email
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the icon located on the lower right
of the screen if you want trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits now please
join me in welcoming dr. Carvalho Silva
I will now turn the presentation over to
her
okay so good morning everyone
Thank You Julie for putting to the
introduction I hope you all have been
joining this virtual conference and I'm
very pleased to be part of it so thank
you very much again for the organizers
for reaching out contacting open targets
and inviting us to take part of this
great event so as Julie said I'm going
to walk you guys through open targets
and so we'll be doing this for the next
45 minutes or so and so my name is Denis
Z and I've been working with open
standards for a year now and we are
based here in Houston just outside
Cambridge in the UK so what I will cover
in this talk I'll tell you guys what
open targets is what the consultant is
what we are all about then I will tell
you the experimental project that we are
involved with and spend a little bit
more time going through the platform so
it's a web interface where you can mind
genes and disease association towards
the end I'll try to highlight what makes
open target unique and then I will also
give you some idea what our plans for
the future so often time this is a
consortium with more than 200 people
involved with mainly in the UK and also
in the u.s. so the talk that I'm
presenting here today is by no means my
own work so this is the contribution and
the hard work of many people within the
consortium so the credit should go all
to them
so some of you may be involved in the
field of drug discovery whereas perhaps
others of you you may be completely new
to the field of drug discovery so you
may not be aware of how long it takes to
identify a drug target to produce that
doctor that drug and then to have it
sold by our pharmacist so it's a very
lengthy process it can take up to twenty
years so from the very start so you have
an idea so you start doing some
identification of your drug target we
have to start doing some research basic
research you will probably be using some
model organisms such as mouse or zebra
fish in order to test how safe your drug
is in those models then you can go on
into the clinical trials which usually
are the most expensive part of this drug
discovery path the clinical trials are
divided up according to different places
and eventually if all goes well your
drug will be approved by the FDA for
example and you'll be able to provide
that to the members of the public so
there are many challenges in the field
of drug discovery so despite being such
a lengthy process it is very costly
especially those stages of the clinical
trials when you're dealing with healthy
volunteers or you're dealing with
patients
and unfortunately the success rate of
discovering new drug targets is very
very low and it varies depending on the
therapeutic area that you are working on
so for example within cardiovascular
diseases it's where we have a higher
percentage of success so it's around 20%
so this means that there is a high
attrition rate you can think of
attrition rate as the number of dropouts
so the number of drug compounds that we
start with in your journey of drug
discovery compared to the number that
you end up with so the number is very
very very low in the causes for this
dropout so the the causes for the
operation can be several fold
and also they vary depending on the
phase of a stage of the drug discovery
timeline so for example when you are
working on the preclinical phase which
is when you are using model organism we
do the mouth and Devilfish so the main
reason for the occasion there is the
safety so 50% of drug targets they tend
to drop out because they are simply not
safe so these changes along the clinical
phases or the clinical trial phases so
whether you move on to phase 1 2 or 3
the main reasons for the dropout is
efficacy so simply the drugs or the drug
target that you are
working on and doing our research that
drug target is simply it simply doesn't
work for their different causes for the
Association so once upon a time here in
Cambridge in the UK we had those three
people having lunch and they were just
talking about drug discovery and they
realize that probably there is room for
improvement here so could we improve the
way that identification of drug targets
is done can we improve it so yes we can
and yes we should and it was also clear
for them that one institution one lab
could not do this on its own so those
people were the director of the Sanger
Institute here in the UK we also had a
dis lunch
occasion we had Patrick Venice which is
the president of our MD in GSK and we
had also a professor Janet Thornton who
at the time was the director of amble
EDI
so those three Minds got together and
launched this idea of open targets so
they launched the consortium in our main
vision is to transform the way that drug
discovery is done so we would like to
combine can genomic experiments we would
like to include statistical rigorous
statute statistical analysis and also
computational techniques to help
identifying drug targets and also to
allow
for the association between drugs genes
diseases and pathways the major core
principles of the consortium is that we
are pre competitive so this means that
we work very much in the early stages of
the drug discovery
we are also aiming at publishing our
data as soon as we have got hold of them
and we are also open to new people
joining us for new groups or new
institutions so those 3 minds that I
talked about earlier so those are Sangha
GSK MAPI so they were the founders of
this consortium so there were our three
founding partners and the consulting
itself was launched in March 2014 so
it's just over three years old now and
we've got a very bold objective so we
would like to be the world leader for
human target discovery so who is open
target now so although we were founded
by JFK ma bi and the Wellcome Trust
Sanger Institute more recently we had
bio jam joining in
so Biogen is the oldest biotechnology
company in the world and it's based in
you in the US if if headquarters are in
Boston and they are very much interested
in diseases such as Alzheimer's
Parkinson's and they have joined up on
target in 2016 so now those are the four
major institutions that make up open
target but as I say
we have it is not an exclusive club if
you want to join open target just get in
touch with us and we can move from there
so this is a little bit of the
background so now I would just like to
highlight the major areas of research
within open target so we've got two
major umbrellas on one hand we've got
people working mainly here at the Sanger
but also at GSK working in the land
so people creating new data we are
working on single-cell RNA sequencing
they are using organized they're using
organoids as well as models of disease
and very much using an Chris cast 9 gene
targeting as well and gene editing so
they are very much using state of art
and very high throughput technologies as
well to create new data using human
cells or orgonites so this is one of the
one of the two major projects within
open time so it's creating new data data
data at the moment completely unheard of
on the other side of the coin we also
have the PI informatics aspects of open
target so at the moment what we are
doing we we have integrated data that
are publicly available with integrated
that into a platform a web interface so
that people
all over the world can go to that place
and my genes and disease associations so
you can do so by using our website but
if you are programmatically inclined if
you know Python for example or you can
get hold of our data through our API or
also perhaps through the data dot so
those two are the two major umbrellas
within open target and they are
concurrent so they are having happening
very much at the same time and if you
want to know more about our projects I
will strongly recommend you guys to have
a look at our link of the battle open
target org forward slash project so from
now on I will focus on the platform
itself just but before I do so I just
like to perhaps highlight that within
the experimental project within the
extra mental projects we are mainly
focusing on oncology so different types
of changes we are also very much working
in the fields of immunology and also
working with Alzheimer's and Parkinson's
disease so those are our major focus
focus in terms of diseases when it comes
to create new data so there are open
target platform which is this other side
of the consortium certain web interface
which was developed by my colleagues
here at the core by formatic cybernetics
team at the ABI and
we would like to allow scientists to use
this platform in order to identify
target and disease associations so by
target here I mean a gene or protein so
the platform is very much frequently
updated and in each of those updates we
may have new data and we can also
include new web features or new tools so
everything that would allow you to
identify gene and disease associations
in one of the most important aspects of
the platform is that everything that we
do here is very much driven by you guys
over there so we take into account
feedback from our user communities and
before internment in a new web feature
or new tool we always consult with our
user communities to see whether or not
this would tailor your needs so this is
the URL for the open target platform so
it's simply that that value the target
validation org outdoor the consortium
itself was launched and founded in March
2014 the platform was relieved for the
very first time in December 2015 so it's
very much if you evolving so it's just
over a year old so it's very much new
but it's moving anything moving as we
speak in one of the most
interesting aspects of the platform as
well is that it it contains various
funky and appealing visualizations so
it's very can catch your eye very easily
so this is our model in order to make
associations between targets and
diseases so it's important to try to
keep this model in mind so in order to
make the association between targets and
diseases we need evidence we need pieces
of evidence that can support that
association and at the moment where do
we get these pieces of evidence from so
we get them from publicly available
databases so on the state table over
here I'm just listing the current set of
data that we've got in the open target
platform so when it comes to genetic
variants or mutations so we get those
from places such as the gif catalog or
uniprot and also a VA which is the
European counterpart of the business
with the added value of having clinvar
data so we've got information of
clinical significance when it comes to
mutations that cause cancer so we've got
those as well and they come mainly from
the cancer gene sensors we also have got
data that shows whether or not a gene is
differentially expressed in healthy in
disease cells we've got drug information
coming from Campbell we've got pathway
information coming from reaction and we
also mined the literature so we mined
millions and millions of scientific
papers out there in research articles
trying to find the link between a target
and the disease and we also have data on
mouse models so all of those disparate
data set they've been combined
integrated and used so that we can give
you millions and millions of
associations between thousands and
thousands of genes and thousands and
thousands of diseases this is by no
means a comprehensive list of datasets
and we are very much interested in
hearing from you if you've got a
favorite data set that you would like to
see in the platform so if that's the
case simply get in touch and let us know
in one of the bedrocks perhaps of plot
of the platform is that the diseases
which are around 9,000 of them at the
moment
human diseases they need to be
classified followed an ontology so you
can think of an ontology is a dictionary
that provides the relationship between
diseases so here for example we we may
be looking at asthma there we are so we
know that asthma is a a child disease
when compared to the spirit or a system
disease and we know that asthma has got
a subtype which is childhood onset
asthma so this is what we call an
ontology a disease ontology so we can
get the relationships between those
diseases
between those entities so the ontology
that we rely on is efo with the
experimental fact ontology created and
maintained here at the API so efo
provides you with this controlled
vocabulary so you can either search for
for example Alzheimer's without or with
the horses and you will get the same
results and we also provide the
hierarchy so you can see what the
relationship between your disease of
interest and its parent and its child
terms so there are several advantages of
relying on an ontology and with very
much need consistency and easy ways to
automate this whole process so this is
just to give you an idea how the data
flows in our pipeline so don't worry too
much about the details here is just to
give you an idea again of the
information with God in terms of
diseases so we've got data coming from
orphanet for rare diseases diseases that
have got I mean Mendelian inheritance we
also have data for common diseases such
as I don't know diabetes some sorts from
some types of diabetes we have some
types of cancer there as well so which
we we are very much we try to be very
comprehensive with the platform and
include as many diseases as we want we
get our ethnic data from a VA and we
validate all the data from those data
sources we also
we make the association between a target
and disease so remember that data model
of ours so we make the Association and
we look at and we give and compute a
score to give you an idea of confidence
how confident you can be on that
association and you can also get data on
the target itself on the gene itself and
also you can get data on the disease so
it's a profile of the disease or profile
of the target so I will skip this way
this is just to show you how the data
looks behind the scenes and also what
are the factors that we take into
account such as this one highlighted in
red and also the final Association is
scores here for a given data type so
again just to give you a flavor of the
sort of data that we hold and we handle
actually behind the scenes so regarding
the score so yes so again this is our
data model here so we use different
types of data sets to make dissociation
between the target and disease but we
need to give you some sort of confidence
on that association and we do so by
giving you a score so again I won't have
time to go through this but this is
scoring is a statistical approach that
was developed by my colleagues you can
get four different types of scores you
can get one at the evidence level at the
data source level data patch level or
the overall score here so so you can get
hold of those numbers and make your own
judgment call
the score will vary from zero to one the
closer to one the stronger we believe in
that association between a target and a
disease so this is just a summary of the
whole process there so we've got our
open targets database here we've got
datasets coming from external databases
those are all publicly available they
have been combined together they have
been scourged and they have been quality
checked and as we speak
we've got my colleagues we've got our
colleagues at the Wellcome Trust Sanger
Institute creating new pieces of
evidence for oncology immunology and
also neural degeneration diseases such
as Alzheimer's and Parkinson's so as
soon as this is if that is available it
will be fed back into the platform or it
will be set back into the public
available databases out there and here I
just have a screen shot of how you can
see this data in the platform so one of
the things we provided this heat map
with different shades of blue the darker
the blue the more strongly the
association between your gene of
interest in a given disease so we do
support decision-making when it comes to
drug discovery and the identification so
we can tell you which time gets
associated with a disease you can use
the platform to find out about the
mechanism of these disease of your own
interest you can use the platform to
find out whether or not they are drugs
that are FDA approved for clinical
trials of jobs that are already on the
market
and you can find lots and lots of
different types of data for your drug
target of interest your gene of interest
and many many many Mon or the use cases
so this is just four examples of things
that you can do with the platform so you
can start from the disease
point of view so you can search in the
platform for your disease of interest
let's say multiple sclerosis so again
here just the reminder for our URLs of
target validation talk so you go in
there you type any disease that you are
interested in and you can get a list of
all possible genes associated with the
disease so this is how it would look
like we've got this table which is a
heat map again different shades of blue
over there the darker the blue they
stronger the Association so the very
first column is the target name or the
target symbol so it's the gene symbol
there then you've got the overall
Association score and their following
column the seven following columns those
are the seven different data types so
we've got genetic associations somatic
mutations drugs pathways that are
affected in diseases we've got data on
expression of RNA which varies between
disease and healthy tissues we have data
being mined from the literature and we
also have got data coming from mouse
models so for each of those seven data
types because a unique Association score
each of those columns can be sorted
you can use this search box there in
order to filter the table on the left
hand side here you can filter by the
data types where the genetic
associations or drugs you can also
filter by pathways you can filter by the
class of your target for example whether
they are membrane receptors or enzymes
perhaps you can filter by including your
own list of targets within multiple
sclerosis here so there's a lot that you
can do so please go ahead and have a
look at this have a look at our yeah
have a look at our platform and give it
a go
so one of the things that you can do as
well so if you if you click on this link
here called view disease profile you'll
be taken to a page that looks like this
so the disease profile page which is
here is URL so this page will give you
information such as the phenotypes
associated with multiple sclerosis it
will also give you all drugs in clinical
trials targeting this disease or using
patients suffering from multiple
sclerosis and you can also get the
disease classification which is the
ontology so you can see that here on the
right hand side in green is my disease
of interest multiple sclerosis and in
blue you've got the different subtypes
of multiple sclerosis and embrace you've
got the parent term within the ontology
of multiple sclerosis
and here is a table just listing all the
32 unique drugs currently in clinical
trials with patients suffering from
multiple sclerosis so that was the
disease centric workflow but you can
also use the platform and in fact your
journey using a target symbol or target
name so if I interested in a given gene
name just go to the target validation
org here typing your Gmail let's say
bracket two and then you can find all
the diseases associated with the target
you will find them back in a breast
cancer and many other types of diseases
associated with brackets you in this
example and you can drill down and find
all the possible pieces of evidence that
we in open targets have used to make the
association between bracket two in all
the diseases that we display in our
platform and finally so so far I have
given some examples on how you can
perform this search using the platform
and it's usually on a one by one and
case basis so you can type in bracket
two and you can get the list of diseases
and then you can type in multiple
sclerosis and you get the list of target
but perhaps you are ready working on the
list of your own favorite target so
let's suppose that you've got some
experiment that highlighted up to 200
genes or targets that you would like to
pursue for the downstream so you can
ideally ideally you would like to
perform this search in a bad
way so you'd like to search for all of
them in one go so very recently we
released what is called a back step back
search - so it's double dot double dot
data validation forward slash batch -
search so over there you can simply
either pasting your list of factors or
you can upload from from your desktop
and you can run that - and we will show
you every single piece of information in
terms of all the diseases associated
with those hundreds of targets of yours
will show the drugs for those targets we
show the pathways those standards are
involved with and possible interactions
between those targets in your list so
these are very much ways of accessing
the data via the web interface and you
will have the the funky visualizations
and it's very intuitive and very easy to
use and it's perfect if you you're
working with one or two targets or
perhaps with 200 standards but not more
than that so they are alternative ways
that you can get hold of our data so you
can download the entire data set in open
targets just be aware that's the file
the size of those files are simply huge
but nevertheless we do make that
available to you so you can just
download those and start mining the
information that you want to on your
terminal window for example so there
won't be any visualizations there for
you but the data you can just do
whatever you want with it
we if you rather have extracts of our
data set so this is in between the web
interface and the file data dump so it
we can do so using our API so if you
know you've got some knowledge of
computer program programming it's very
easy to use and we'd have a REST API so
again I won't have time to go through
these or give more details but I think
it surprises to say and to highlight
that there are alternative ways to get
hold of the data and we would like to
encompass everyone in the scientific
community those who know how to program
but also those who do not know how to
program so whichever group you belong to
you will have a way to get hold of our
data so I think we've got perhaps less
than than 20 minutes left
everything so I would like maybe they
have to just try to wrap up by
highlighting the reasons why we think of
integrity is unique why is this
consortium unique so first of all we are
trying to address as many areas of human
diseases as we can especially when it
comes to the platform we have no bias
whatsoever providing the data is out
there publicly available we will
integrate the data and provide it to you
we also very much put our users first so
we want to hear from you guys what is
missing in the platform what we do well
what we should be through home so there
is no point in providing this platform
or providing this data and then not
being useful to you guys so you guys
need to comfort and you do comfort in
this consortium we also do work at the
genome-wide level so we are interested
in protein coding genes in non-coding
genes as well intergenic regions and we
are looking throughout the human genome
as well so with just with
focus just on exonic regions for example
and we also will perform genomic the
genomic experiments but also
transcriptomics and we'll be doing some
metabolomics research as well and
another very unique aspect of the
consortium
is that we do put we do bring the
partners together so at the moment those
are our four current partners so Biogen
there in Boston we've got a VI here in
the UK GSK UK in US and also the single
Institute here in the UK
so those four renowned institutions
working together being brought together
back by the consortium exchanging
information exchanging ideas
collaborating together sitting next to
each other I've got a colleague from the
u.s. city here next to me in the UK so
we are very much collaborative and
everyone has got to say within the team
so what is coming up next so at the
moment you can search for a target name
or target symbol you can also search for
your disease of interest you can search
for drugs so you can type in a drug
whether it's a common name or a
commercial name you can tag that in and
you can get information that open target
has integrated for you you can also
search for phenotypes so what is coming
up next we would like to allow you guys
to search for genetic variants such as
is numbers from the business we would
also like to allow you to be to search
for pathway IDs and also PubMed IDs so
the other thing we would like to provide
at the moment we provide only targets
and disease associations and we are
working on visual ways to represent
target and target association and
disease and disease associations so the
scope or the universe of associations
will go beyond target and disease only
and the other thing we are doing at the
moment we are taking to account
functional genomics and functional
studies in order to assign genetic
variants to drug targets so that will be
very much
perhaps by July by September you will
have ways that you can access some
functional information as well that will
be included in the platform so I would
like just to mention that for more
details I would really recommend you
guys to look at this publication here at
the nucleus in a nucleic acids research
so we are very pleased that this paper
of ours was selected as a breakthrough
article in the end of last year so it's
a great place to go and get all the
detailed information on how the platform
was put together here at the ABI and
finally I would just like also to say
that we are very much open to hear your
comments your suggestions we do have an
outreach team here so we provide we give
your support so the best way we have to
get in touch with us is by emailing us
and so you can use this email address
there but we are also very much active
on social media giving you hints and
tips on how to use the platform we also
we are every now and again we are
recruiting new members for the team so
it's a good place especially our twitter
account it's a good place to go and have
a look at the jobs that
available there so and we've got lots
actually we've got two and gif
animations as well which are highlighted
there for you so you can go to those sit
back relax and for a minute or two you
will see how you can navigate through
the platform I won't have time to do a
live demo here but you can just check
those gif animations and they will give
you an extra flavor of what you can do
with the platform on one by one case
basis and here I've got the animation on
the back batch search tool so you can
see how you can search for hundreds and
hundreds of targets in one go so I think
that's very much what I wanted to say so
I hope it was useful for you guys so I
think now perhaps we may be open to a
couple questions I'll be delighted to
answer questions if there are any of
those thank you very much
Thank You dr. kravaal have Silvester
that informative
formative presentation we will now start
the live Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the green
2 + 8 button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the spin button well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for if we are unable to get to your
question we will follow up with you via
email after the presentation let's get
started our first question is how long
does the platform get updated with new
data ok yes thank you for your question
and yeah so the platform at the moment
it gets updated every two to three
months so we depart the pipeline is
rather time consuming as it stands but
we are working and trying to speed that
up a little bit and we are aiming as
providing updates on a monthly basis but
as it stands it's between two to three
months great thank you for that answer
the next question is do you have
information on drugs which clinical
trials have failed
so our information on drugs come from
Kemble which is a database for drugs and
compounds here at amble ABI so at the
moment we don't have a way to find out
whether or not the drug failed on
clinical trials but we are working on
ways to incorporate that information but
at the moment we don't have information
on sale of the drugs
appreciate that and we'll wrap up with
one more question and that question is
do you have proteomics data
so when your search for a target so
let's suppose bracket 2 which is the
gene or target associated with breast
cancer so when you search for Backa 2 so
you can get proteomics data coming from
the human protein Atlas database so you
can find out what is the expression
level at the protein for that given gene
and we are now working on trying to
incorporate more proteomics data and
also give a more comprehensive landscape
so for your targets of interest great
thank you so much and that will do it
for the questions for today I would like
to once again thank dr. Carvalho Silva
for her presentation and I would like to
also thank Roberts for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 25th
2017 you will receive an email from
glabrous letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye